Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour.
Je m’appelle Hicham Mansouri,
je suis journaliste marocain,
membre de la rédaction d’Orient 21,
réfugié en France
et co-fondateur de l’Association marocaine
pour le journalisme d’investigation, AMJI.
Le 24 septembre 2015, alors que je sortais
d’une réunion de travail dans un hôtel,
je suis violemment agressé par deux
inconnus, au physique sportif,
qui ont pris la fuite à bord
d’une voiture qui les attendait.
Transporté aux urgences,
les médecins me prescrivent une incapacité
totale temporaire de 25 jours.
Et la plainte déposée contre X
a été classée.
La police n’a en effet pas récupéré les
images de la vidéo-surveillance de l’hôtel
sur lesquelles on voit pourtant la
voiture des agresseurs quitter les lieux.
Les mois suivant mon agression sont
marqués par une surveillance physique,
mais aussi en ligne.
À plusieurs reprises,
je remarque des filatures
et j’envoie même les numéros
d’immatriculation des voitures
qui stationnent près de mon appartement
et qui me suivent.
Les mois suivant mon agression physique
sont marqués par
une intense surveillance physique,
mais aussi en ligne.
Numériquement,
des alertes me préviennent de tentatives
de piratage de mes comptes de messagerie,
d’autres de connexions étranges,
et le navigateur affiche que ma
connexion n’est pas sécurisée.
Mon anti-malware, censé me protéger,
m’avertit qu’il ne protège pas mon
ordinateur de deux adresses IP
qu’il considère comme
deux exceptions ajoutées.
Or, je ne les ai pas ajoutées
et il est impossible de les supprimer
même après désinstallation
et réinstallation du logiciel.
Autrement dit, mon ordinateur
fait confiance à deux adresses IP
sur lesquelles j’ignore tout.
Je décide alors de faire une enquête
sur cette potentielle surveillance
et j’en informe deux collègues
de confiance.
Naturellement, je contacte aussi
le fabricant du logiciel pour lui demander
si ce qu’il se passe,
ces deux exceptions, est naturel.
Sa réponse, malgré sa prudence, comme
c’est le cas de ce genre de messages,
à la fois diplomatiques et commerciaux,
confirme mes soupçons
et renforce l’hypothèse de l’existence
d’une surveillance électronique.
Je la reçois le 16 mars 2015.
Seulement le lendemain, comme par hasard,
je suis arrêté par la police.
Le matin du 17 mars 2015,
dix agents de police en civil défoncent
la porte de mon appartement,
m’agressent, me déshabillent,
me filment nu
et je suis poursuivi d’adultère
et condamné à dix mois de prison ferme,
avant d’être poursuivi six mois plus tard,
pendant que je vais purger ma peine
d’atteinte à la sûreté interne de l’État
pour mon travail avec l’ONG
néerlandaise Free Press Unlimited.
Le 19 mars 2015, on m’a conduit
à la prison de Salé 1, située à Rabat.
C’est une des prisons les plus
dangereuses et les plus surpeuplées,
avec un taux de 173%.
«Ici, on va bien s’occuper de toi.»
C’est une phrase que j’ai entendue le
premier jour d’un gardien qui me reçoit.
Pour se venger de moi,
on m’a affecté dans un bloc, le bloc D,
que les détenus les plus récidivistes
appellent Zabbala, en arabe : la poubelle.
Séjourner dans ce bloc
vous donne le titre de « microbe »,
pour utiliser le jargon carcéral.
Censées accueillir quinze personnes,
les cellules abritent en réalité 40
à 60 personnes, selon les périodes.
Notre cellule, qui mesure
36 mètres carrés...
Dans notre cellule de 36 mètres carrés,
nous étions une quarantaine.
Faute de place, la majorité des détenus
dorment par terre, tête bêche,
et sont obligés d’attendre leur tour
pour avoir un lit,
une plaque métallique d’un mètre sur 75 -
d′1,75 mètre sur 50, 60 cm.
Comme je suis le dernier arrivé,
il me fallait dormir par terre,
près du coin toilettes sans porte,
sur un sol mouillé et crasseux.
Comme tout le monde, mon corps
a été rapidement envahi de poux.
L’administration pénitentiaire
ne met en place aucun règlement
quant à l’heure du couvre-feu.
Les discussions et les bagarres
continuent jusqu’à tard la nuit,
souvent jusqu’au matin.
Dans ces conditions,
il est impossible de dormir
à cause des bagarres, de la fumée,
de la musique forte
et surtout de la violence.
Les détenus se bagarrent et
s’auto-mutilent avec des lames de rasoir,
de couteaux, de tournevis ou de tout
autre objet pointu ou saillant.
Certains de ces détenus violents sont même
atteints de troubles psychologiques.
La délégation générale à l’administration
pénitentiaire a toujours nié
ces conditions de détention jusqu’en 2017,
où elle décide de la démolir.
Pour la première fois, les portes de
cette prison ont été ouvertes aux médias
et on a pu voir la réalité.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez
déjà vu les images.
Pendant ces 10 mois, je suis passé
par 5 cellules de trois blocs différents
et j’ai pu côtoyer des détenus condamnés
pour différents crimes,
comme le trafic de drogue,
vol à main armée et même terrorisme.
J'ai pu gagner leur confiance.
Et dès le premier jour
de mon incarcération,
je suis surpris de les voir
consommer les mêmes produits
pour lesquels beaucoup d’entre eux
ont été incarcérés.
Il s'agit notamment du cannabis.
Ils consomment ces trafics
jusqu’à 3 h du matin au plus tard.
Et pour la plupart,
la vie reprend vers midi.
Les gardiens et les fonctionnaires sont
la cheville ouvrière de tous ces trafics,
car il est impossible de se lancer
dans ce business sans eux.
Les détenus les appellent
d’ailleurs Mwali l’wakt
c’est-à-dire les maîtres du temps.
Plusieurs trafics prospèrent
et je vais me limiter à quelques exemples.
Il y a d’abord, comme je l’ai dit,
le trafic du cannabis.
Dans cette prison, le cannabis arrive
chaque dimanche vers 16 h.
Un dimanche parce que pendant le week-end,
il n’y a pas de promenade,
un moment de détente, de «zemta»
qui veut dire : l’étouffement.
Il y a moins de mouvements,
moins de fonctionnaires.
Pour livrer leur marchandise,
les dealers peuvent prolonger
leur promenade.
Les promenades se font uniquement
dans les couloirs et non dans la cour.
Curieusement, les caméras de surveillance
ne fonctionnent pas.
Mais malgré cela, par précaution,
les gardiens choisissent un angle
non couvert par le champ des caméras.
La marchandise atterrit
ensuite dans la cellule,
mais elle n’y reste pas longtemps
parce qu’elle est tout de suite
stockée dans une autre cellule,
où un autre détenu, souvent
des Subsahariens, sert de fusible
et il est rémunéré pour ce risque.
Pour donner un exemple, en prison,
100 grammes de cannabis, coûte en moyenne
6000 dirhams, soit environ 560€.
La même quantité dehors
coûte dix fois moins cher,
sachant que la qualité en prison
est très mauvaise.
Second exemple, les psychotropes.
Tard dans la journée,
les détenus dorment encore.
Les premiers jours, je vois certains
avec une mousse blanchâtre
qui sort de leur bouche.
« Il a avalé un comprimé de Rosina, »
m’explique un détenu.
Il y a une multitude de psychotropes qui
portent des noms marocains, parfois,
comme «horida » la petite fleur,
«hench », le serpent ou «Prada».
Se lancer dans le business du psychotrope
est encore plus facile
parce qu’il suffit de corrompre
le médecin de la prison,
100 à 200 dirhams
pour avoir une ordonnance.
Les détenus m’expliquent avoir recours
à ces psychotropes
pour bien dormir et oublier.
Au regard
de l’administration pénitentiaire,
un détenu qui dort
est un problème de moins.
Il semble que,
malgré leurs effets collatéraux,
ces psychotropes contribuent beaucoup
à la paix sociale en prison.
Un matin, un détenu me lance :
«Toi aussi, tu te drogues.»
Ne comprenant pas s’il s’agit
d’une question, d’une affirmation,
ou même d’une blague,
il enchaîne et m’explique qu’on nous
met des psychotropes dans les repas.
Je lui demande s’il a des preuves
et il m’explique,
parce qu’il est ce qu’on appelle
un homme de corvée,
qu’il travaille dans la cuisine,
et il y une seule tâche à laquelle
il ne participe jamais,
c’est l’ajout des épices,
un mélange dont il ignore
totalement la composition.
Au début, je ne prenais pas
ces révélations au sérieux,
tellement elles sont dangereuses.
Mais vers la fin de mon séjour carcéral,
au moment d’un recours expérimental
à un prestataire externe
dans la préparation des repas,
d’autres détenus m’en reparlent.
Un détenu salafiste me dit :
«Ça y est, les bagarres vont éclater
puisque les repas ne sont plus
préparés en prison.»
Étrangement, le soir même, je remarque
que les bagarres deviennent
de plus en plus fréquentes,
à commencer par notre cellule.
Il y a aussi le marché du papier à rouler
qui accompagne celui du cannabis.
Un paquet de papier à rouler est revendu
à 150 dirhams, soit 14€.
Le paquet vendu au détail par feuille
peut rapporter 225 dirhams.
Dehors, un paquet ne coûte que
quatre dirhams, soit environ 0,30€ euro.
Le prix très cher du papier à rouler
et parfois sa rupture du stock
poussent les détenus à chercher
des alternatives.
La plus connue que j’ai pu remarquer,
c’est la cellophane.
Je suis très surpris le premier jour
où un détenu me demande
de lui vendre une boîte de thé
à un prix plus élevé -
Il me demande de lui vendre
l’emballage de la boîte de thé
à un prix plus élevé
que la boîte elle-même.
Un marché qui échappe à toute logique.
Les détenus coupent ces emballages de thé
en morceaux et les utilisent
pour rouler leurs joints.
Il m’explique que le joint roulé
en cellophane a un effet plus fort
et il dure trois fois plus longtemps.
Dernier exemple.
Chaque bloc en prison est équipé
de deux à cinq postes téléphoniques fixes.
Les détenus peuvent les utiliser
pour appeler leur famille
pendant les heures de promenade.
Mais trois facteurs changent la donne.
D'abord, le nombre élevé des détenus.
Nous étions 1000 [détenus] dans le bloc D.
Et bien sûr,
le nombre de téléphones fixes,
dont la moitié, en général,
ne fonctionne pas.
Et puis surtout, la durée très courte de
la promenade, notamment dans le bloc D,
qui dure deux fois 20 minutes par jour.
Tous ces facteurs,
forcent, obligent les détenus
à se procurer un téléphone portable.
Il s’agit de téléphones portables basiques
qui coûtent dehors 300 dirhams, 28€.
Ils sont revendus en prison
dix fois plus cher.
Et plus la prison est loin de la ville,
plus les prix sont élevés.
Ils peuvent atteindre 1 000€
dans certaines prisons.
Les opérations de vente sont
systématiquement poursuivies
d’opérations de fouille.
Les équipes de fouille semblent connaître
non seulement les cellules concernées,
mais aussi les acheteurs
et parfois même les cachettes.
Les téléphones saisis sont revendus
dans d'autres quartiers.
Dans les témoignages que
j’ai pu collecter auprès des détenus,
dans le bloc M1, c’est un détenu
qui s’appelle Mahmoud,
un détenu qui a un laissez-passer oral,
qui lui permet de circuler librement
dans toute l’enceinte de la prison,
qui se charge de les acheminer
et les revendre dans d’autres quartiers.
Ainsi, la stratégie de l'administration
se résume comme suit.
Laisser se dégrader ou dégrader
les rares téléphones fixes
afin de pousser les détenus à acheter
les téléphones portables du marché,
gérés par l’administration,
à des prix dix fois plus élevés,
les saisir pendant les fouilles,
puis les revendre.
Et le cycle recommence.
C’est la naissance
d’une économie circulaire.
En prison, tout est un business.
Tout peut être vendu.
Pendant dix mois, j’ai enquêté
sur tous ces business et d’autres.
J’ai pu gagner la confiance
de plusieurs gardiens,
et bien sûr, des détenus.
Parmi les gardiens,
il y avait même un ancien gradé
de l’administration pénitentiaire
qui voulait se venger
d’un système qui l’a rejeté.
J’ai écrit chaque jour 30 blocs-notes
que j’ai rassemblés dans mon livre :
«Au cœur d’une prison marocaine.
Enquête sur le royaume
de tous les trafics.»
Le livre dessine, comme vous l'avez
compris, la cartographie de l'interdit.
Et sa conclusion est que
tous ces business dépassent
les frontières de la prison
parce qu’ils ne peuvent pas
fonctionner de cette manière
sans l’implication des appareils
judiciaires et aussi policiers.
Car c’est eux qui en assurent la clientèle
et la main-d’œuvre que sont les détenus.
En prison, le trafic ne se limite pas à
ces exemples que je viens de donner.
Il y a aussi celui des réchauds,
des matelas, de la viande, des œufs,
des couteaux et tout autre objet.
Il y a aussi les télévisions.
À chaque fois, la stratégie est la même :
interdire des produits,
étouffer les alternatives, proposer
des solutions, saisir et revendre.
Bref, créer un problème,
offrir une solution, saisir et revendre.
Le Maroc compte 75 prisons
avec 80 000 détenus.
On peut donc imaginer le chiffre
d’affaires faramineux
de ce business juteux,
probablement aussi deviner les acteurs,
ceux qui en bénéficient.
Je quitte donc la prison
avec la conclusion
que nous sommes face à une
grande entreprise à plusieurs filiales,
dont la main-d’œuvre et les clients
sont les détenus
et le conseil d’administration est
composé de l’administration pénitentiaire,
la justice et la police.
Cela explique probablement le temps de
détention provisoire très élevé au Maroc :
39% si on se réfère
aux chiffres officiels.
Devant cette situation, des détenus,
des petits trafiquants notamment,
semblent parfois mieux goûter
à l’enfermement qu’à la liberté.
Ils maîtrisent les codes
de cette société miniature
où les règles sont plus cohérentes
et plus claires,
et surtout un milieu où
on ne risque pas grand-chose,
où, comme me l’explique un détenu,
il n’y a pas de police.
Ces détenus gagnent mieux
leur vie en prison.
Ils travaillent en prison.
Ils ne sortent que pour voir la famille
et profiter d’un peu de liberté.
Ces détenus appellent ces va-et-vient
«bomby», c’est-à-dire rebondir.
Le projet de création
de l’Association marocaine pour
le journalisme d’investigation
remonte à 2009.
Découvrant le nom de l’association,
un agent de la préfecture
répond à l’un des fondateurs
venu déposer le dossier d’agrément :
«Seule la police fait
des investigations.»
Les autorités ont tout fait
pour bloquer ce projet
en demandant, par exemple,
des documents non exigés par la loi,
voire en piratant notre site Internet
qui a été remplacé
par un contenu pornographique.
La reconnaissance de l’AMJI n’a eu lieu
que le 22 février 2011,
soit deux jours après le mouvement
du 20 février,
la version marocaine du Printemps arabe.
Notre reconnaissance a eu lieu
dans un moment d’ouverture politique
grâce au vent du Printemps arabe.
L’AMJI a organisé des formations
en journalisme d’enquête,
a octroyé des prix et des bourses
pour promouvoir ce genre journalistique.
Et surtout, il s’est étendu, avec
des sections régionales sur treize villes.
Les productions journalistiques financées
par l’AMJI semblent vite déranger.
Assassinat politique sur Hassan II,
prédation économique, économie de rente...
Voici quelques personnes qui ont fait
partie de près ou de loin de ce projet.
On y trouve des fondateurs,
des formateurs et des conférenciers,
et puis des lauréats de nos prix
et de nos bourses.
Et j'ajoute deux journalistes
pour illustrer mes propos.
Tous sont poursuivis,
ont fait de la prison,
ou y sont en ce moment-même.
Vous l’avez peut-être deviné,
comme pour moi, les accusations
n’ont rien à voir avec leurs activités.
La stratégie consiste à chaque fois
de les poursuivre avec
des accusations de droit commun
afin de les salir d’abord,
avant de les punir
et surtout pour éviter les soutiens.
On distingue trois grandes
catégories d’accusation.
Des accusations sécuritaires
comme l’atteinte à la sûreté de l’État,
apologie du terrorisme, espionnage.
Des accusations financières : blanchiment
d’argent, détournement de fonds,
escroquerie.
Et des accusations sexuelles : avortement,
adultère, viol, trafic humain.
Je répète que ce sont
des accusations fausses,
sans quoi ces gens-là ne seraient pas
soutenus par des ONG
comme l’Association marocaine
pour les droits de l’Homme,
Amnesty, Human Rights Watch, etc.
Ils sont parfois même soutenus
par leurs victimes, victimes présumées,
lorsque celles-ci existent.
Et certaines de ces victimes présumées
changent de camp et deviennent accusés
lorsqu’elles refusent de collaborer
avec la police.
Certains ont été la cible de plusieurs
de ces catégories en même temps.
Ça a été le cas pour moi-même.
Ça a été le cas pour Omar Radi,
qui a déjà été incarcéré pour un tweet.
Ça a été aussi le cas d’un journaliste
historien, Mehdi Mouji,
qui vient d’être libéré suite à
une très grande campagne de soutien
à l’échelle internationale et nationale,
mais qui est aujourd’hui interdit
de quitter le territoire,
y compris pour aller se soigner
à l’étranger,
étant donné qu’il est cardiaque
et diabétique.
Omar Radi,
journaliste d’investigation
qui a beaucoup travaillé sur des enquêtes
liées à l’économie de rente
est condamné à six mois de prison ferme
pour viol, ivresse, espionnage
et d’autres accusations.
La liste est longue.
Taoufik Bouachrine est condamné
à 15 ans de prison ferme
pour viol et trafic humain.
Soulaimane Raissouni est condamné
à cinq ans de prison ferme pour viol.
Les deux derniers sont respectivement
le rédacteur en chef
et le directeur de publication
du quotidien Akhbar Al Youm.
C’est l’un des derniers journaux
indépendants au Maroc,
aujourd’hui fermé par les autorités, suite
à une campagne de boycott publicitaire.
En ce moment même,
les trois sont en prison.
Inversement à moi,
la punition est différente.
Ils sont en isolement total,
ils ne rencontrent personne,
ne parlent à personne,
y compris pendant les promenades.
Tous, comme moi et bien d’autres
que je ne cite pas,
car je me limite à quelques personnes qui
ont gravité autour du projet de l’AMJI,
sont la cible du logiciel espion Pegasus,
selon les dernières révélations
de Forbidden Stories
et Amnesty International.
J’aurais pu faire une liste de dizaines,
voire des centaines d’autres personnes,
si j’inclus les militants du mouvement
du Hirak du Rif par exemple,
qui peuvent rentrer dans ce genre
d’accusation, notamment sécuritaires.
Ces nouvelles méthodes
et stratégies très sales
qui visent à punir,
se limitent donc
à un échantillon plus vaste.
Et si ces personnes-là sont visées, c’est
parce qu’elles ont dénoncé la corruption.
Pour d’autres, comme les trois
journalistes que je viens de citer,
pour avoir révélé cette corruption
au plus haut sommet de l’État.
Et qu’on a retrouvé au cœur des prisons
dans lesquelles ils croupissent
injustement.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)